leute was geht ab hier ist max und wir
spielen heute eine rundes kairos ich
habe mal diese energie cat genommen ich
habe noch kein video anzusehen
und überhaupt eigentlich noch gar nichts
damit
was ist der sinn der sache nicht vermute
einfach man kann sie in die luft
schießen
vermutlich auch aber also wegen hier
wassereimer und wahrscheinlich die nt
kanone bauen keinen plan warum man das
machen unser erster schritt die okay wir
machen jetzt einfach diese energie stil
wenn wir schon in diesem leisten m lg
modus drin sind dann müssen wir es auch
machen
roubini lustig alter der frist hat noch
geholt hereinzubringen ist riskant und
ich habe immer nicht verstanden was das
kit bringt aber wir probieren es gleich
nochmal aus so da sind jetzt auch in
runde 21 19 es einfach problems
warum mache ich jetzt mal die techniker
direkt am anfang hey ich will ja dass
sie was bringt die bremer klar bringt
die was an wenn man ja über gebaut
du bist jetzt auf der nächsten karte
western und ich kenne die glaube ich
nicht mal wir probieren jetzt mal
irgendwie etwas cooles zu machen wasser
wasser war hier sicher bald könnte er
mich runter schlagen wollen
madame um experimente oder oder nächste
hey wie gehts noch ich will irgendwie
einen coolen moves rein kriegen und ich
stoppt die zeit ob twitter nicht spielen
das erste mal dieses tnt dies entschied
wie gesagt nicht dass jetzt hengst okay
die ganzen anderen schaffen dass
johannes bestimmt alles schon ein paar
mal gestaltete nach gestoppt
viel braucht exakt vier sekunden von der
aktivierung bis zur explosion
also 123 also hier zum beispiel wartet
und 12 japanische stadt forum
eigentlich ist das jahr eine spielerei
zeugs das ist ist ja eigentlich nur
darum cool auszusehen
ihr neues logo outlook outlook rollt
alter was was was alter schwede schon
gemacht als er gefressen
grassmann schleichen gleichen
schleichend gleichen gleichen steigen
wir werden probieren leute wir geben
nicht auf
ltd
da sind die nächsten gegner leute
erwartet kommt uns relativ gelegen
siehst du diesen durchschuss durch
schoss aber genau gerade drauf will
quasi das dann erwogen aber keine
ruhepause den bogen des crafter dann
wäre glaube ich also ich dachte der wort
jetzt hoch damit der zu mir komm ich
will es einmal schaffen leute da muss
doch was macht denn dies kann auch gut
wenn eine drinbleibt sollen mir
vielleicht probieren tnt auf mehr
unterwerfen zu werfen
ja in seinem kopf web alter muss ja auch
sachen probieren
leute das sind die eigentlichen energy -
wofür möchten die komplett in dem 14
ich auf jeden fall stark wie ich das kit
ihr zu meinem vorteil einsetzen
aufgemacht das habe ich ja okay das hat
jemand anders mit dem kit surfen was
erwartet er sich dafür zur kaffeetasse
stellt drei spieler verbleiben ich will
jetzt was cooles machen ja egal aber ich
habe schon mal den 12
die us-streitkräfte kannst alles kräften
herr kollege
junge und ich viel gewonnen und du hast
du gefragt was ich mache nichts bedeute
grünes halt das kann ich jetzt seht ihr
ich bin doch zu was zu gebrauchen ich
sitze als 25 minuten wirklich also es
ist genau 25 jetzt erst mal das kind
benutzt habe dafür finde ich das schon
zumute aktion ist gerade am ende
ich hoffe euch hat sie auch gefallen
dass sie was beim nächsten mal wieder
und bis dahin